do you ever have fans that are emotional
or talk to you about like how it changed
their life or it meant so much to them I
I was at the airport and I I was and
there was someone walking by she was a a
flight attendant and she came back with
someone else like one of her co-workers
and she just started to cry and said you
know she was so alone and she but she
could watch you know a show every single
night and know that like she could come
home to that and then I start crying
because I said and she's like I know you
probably think I sound crazy I'm like no
you're not crazy at all um I have the
same thing like I have those same
feelings and I have shows that I'm come
home to and I've also learned that like
I feel really grateful to have learned
like that it's such a waste of time to
be cool like all the cool people in the
world are really like the fans you know
what I mean like people who are willing
to be fanatic about something that they
love that's cool